This series of videos,
we'll explore the basic grammar of
the romance languages by comparing and
contrasting late Latin
and its descendants.
This first video is a short introduction
providing some general thoughts before
we just jump right in.
Yeah,
the Roman Empire Spread Latin
as it conquered it's way
throughout ancient Europe.
Local popular forms of Latin collectively
called Vulgar Latin developed over the
centuries changing as languages do into
a variety of languages and dialects
across the continent.
Some of these languages even spread
across the globe and continued to develop
far from their original homes.
Nowadays there are five major
romance languages, French, Spanish,
Portuguese, Italian, and Romanian.
Those are probably names you recognize,
but there are other regional languages
like Sicilian and Katelyn and extinct
languages like Dalmatian that give us a
more complete picture of this language
family.
So what is a comparative grammar of
the Romance Languages? Very briefly,
a grammar is how a language works.
So a romance grammar will tell you,
we're giving you an idea of
how the romance languages work.
This grammar will be comparative because
instead of just looking at individual
languages like just
French or only Spanish,
we'll explore examples from
multiple languages in each topic.
Okay?
Throughout this series, I'm going
to display examples on your screen,
vulgar Latin examples.
We'll start with an asterisk.
That little star is going to tell you
that vulgar Latin words are reconstructed.
They come from a mostly
undocumented form of Latin.
If you want to learn how extinct
undocumented languages are reconstructed,
I share a lot more in a separate series
covering the basics of historical
linguistics. I'll put a link to
that below. Here's one example.
Classical Latin writers used.
Look, Ward four I speak,
but some late Latin speakers started
saying Bonobo and others started saying
fall below four I speak instead.
Examples in languages other than Latin
in the modern romance languages start
with an asterisk.
When they offer negative evidence.
Negative examples are reasonable
structures that tend not to show up in a
language. For example, English
speakers say my language,
but don't really say the my language.
Well in Italian the
opposite is actually true,
but don't take my word for these really.
You can get a taste of the frequency
of any of these examples by starting to
search for similar structures online.
Positive examples should come up a lot
more frequently than negative ones.
If the negative rate even
returns any results at all.
Okay,
let's divide romance words up.
We'll split them up based on whether
or not each word has different forms.
In English,
the word hat as a plural form hats,
these kinds of words are variable.
Other words like two in to a party are
invariable in the romance languages.
Content, words like nouns and
verbs can very well function.
Words like prepositions and
conjunctions tend not to vary,
so how do variable words very not
in any old way, variable words,
very in a very specific way.
They have a base that carries the
meaning like this Spanish base
we call this basis stem endings attached
to the end of this stem and often carry
some grammatical information.
That Spanish stem fluke deal and
can be used in the verb. When Fiona,
it works, it works, and so on.
We'll treat these variations as
different forms of the same word,
not as completely different words.
Let's build on these ideas in upcoming
lessons as we start to look into how
nouns, verbs, pronouns,
adjectives, and adverbs,
particles and sentences work
in the romance languages.
I'm really excited to start
sharing some examples with you.
You're going to meet some
very cool languages and get
a good sense for how this
family works. Ballet.
That's good. Bye for now,
and I look forward to next time.